こんにちは阪神社長ですみんな健康に
キッズ使っててください
こんにちははじめしゃちょーですなんか
おしゃれに見えますけどこれGUコーデと
いうわけで今年もやってまいりました
健康診断の結果
まあより詳しいものにしようということで
毎年はじめしゃちょーはさっき叫びすぎて
頭痛い前に沸騰し始め社長並びに初めに
株式会社宇宙の会社では全社員健康第一と
いうことで人間ドックを受けさせて
いただいております人間ドックっていうの
は
健康診断よりもこう精密な検査というか
よりこう体に異常がないかとかバリウム
飲んでこの胃に怪しい影がないかとか割と
精密に健康診断以上に
体にヤバいとこがないかとか見る検査やっ
てるんですけども今年もですねもう年始に
私受けていきまして
[音楽]
前回が結構
ひどかったんですよなんか体重は爆増して
たしなんだっけ中性脂肪なんか
コレステロールちょっとよくわかんないん
ですけど色々とちょっとかなり問題があり
ましてなんかそれをきっかけに俺今日ね
ダイエットとかやってたじゃないですか
応答ファジーとか始めてみてなんか普通に
1ヶ月で急遽痩せたりだとかなんか色々体
に気を使うというどっちかっていうとこう
対象を落とすというか増えてきた
肉を減らすみたいな動きを結構してみたん
ですけどもその結果が今回もう帰ってきて
ます
封筒で
それがこちらですいや来ちゃいましたが
ついにちょいまだ見てないので本当にま
初めて見ますこの
結果が良かったら今日
ラーメン食いに行ってきますなんかね
ポイントとしてはねやばかったら赤い印が
ついてるんすよそれが付いてるかついて
ないかあと再計算の神が入ってるか入って
ないかですねいきます
最近
[拍手]
行きますよはい
なんか
これどうなんだろうなぁ
[音楽]
あったんですよ行かなかったけど申し訳
ないですあの
オートファジーでうまく体重減らしてたん
で行かなくていいやと思って行ってないん
ですけど今回は
再検査はなさそうですねよしよしよしよし
なんかそれなりに問題はなかったっぽいか
なよしよくなってる気がするけどまだ
ちょっと
スーツ的な良くないのかなわかんないけど
ちょっと見ていこうと思いますまず身長
なんかめっちゃ減ってんだよな身長が
前回186.1だったので今回
185.40.7cm
縮んでますねなんか朝早送りした時って
身長ちょっと伸びてるんですよこれ朝一
だったんですけどこれ前日そんなに寝て
なくて多分そういう関係もあると思います
変動なしと体重が前回73キロに比べて
今回70点8-約3キロの減量に成功して
おりますまあこれはオートファジーを
引き続き続けた結果かなだとしてもね結構
増えた方だった本当はねもっとやばい時俺
65kgとかだったから割と何かそれなり
に程よい体重には持っていって図らせて
いただきました肥満とかマイナス6.3も
マイナスの時点でOKって感じじゃない
ですか
BMIが20.6体脂肪率14.9お腹
周りがおー77.5前回よりちょっと
小さくなってますね血圧の問題なし視力も
問題なしと眼圧も多分問題になし聴力も
問題になし尿検査
全体的に問題になって今回初めてタンパク
が0でした前回と全前回は10って出てた
んですけどもこれなんでだろうな触って
ないからかな
政府ですで肝臓系クレアチニンていうのも
今回前回かかったんですけども大丈夫と
ギリギリラインだったけど大丈夫
尿酸も前回赤かったね今回セーフでしたで
問題の脂質系ですよ油っぽいものが好きな
のでここが問題
前回と比べて総コレステロールはマシには
なりましたね235ただギリギリだね
ほんとギリギリldlコレステロール値も
まあ
割と下がった方かな前回166だったから
の
adh何これ何これ
[音楽]
LDH
ディズニーなのコレステロールが173
前回のも減ってますがまだ赤いとで今回
やばかったのがね中性脂肪が2005
これついに来たかこれついに来てるんじゃ
ないかって思うんだけど中性脂肪大丈夫か
爆上がりしてるけど修正すればってあれ
でしょなんかマジで油っぽいものの食べ
過ぎ的なやつでしょここ最近の唯一の俺の
欠点としては
大食いめっちゃやっちゃうんですよなんか
ワルノでそれだな
じゃあいいやよくありません次から気を
つけます空腹時血糖もちょっと105と
赤くなってますねー何これ
肝臓系のALTこれだいぶ下がったけど
なんか赤いですね
肝臓も良くないのかな
めっちゃお酒飲んでるわけじゃないんです
けどねそれ以外も色々ありますけども全体
的にはまあ問題がなかったといったところ
でしょうかまあほんと1つ不安なのは
引き続き全体的に判定Aなんですけど
脂質ね脂質系がまあ
即生活ねー
誰か料理してくれどうしてもコンビニだっ
たり外食だったりラーメンとんかつ食べ
てるせいでま中性脂肪以外は前回より良く
なりましたけどちょっとまた高いという
ことでここがまだかなり問題かなと思い
ますいやでもまず良かったそれ以外は
オッケー石コメント来年も検診を受けて
異常な変化を見る必要があります
症状なのが出た時は早めにかかりつけまた
専門に受診して相談してください
わかりましたいや大丈夫でしょうこれは
さすがにどう見ても大丈夫です
多分
入ってないよねほんとに
再計算に
再現差ないのマジで嬉しい
第一くんとかめっちゃ最近さしてたからね
毎年言ってる気がするけど20代の後半に
なるとマジで普通にご飯食べてても太るん
すよもう体がそういう風にできてきてんの
多分成長期じゃないから食べれば食べる分
だけ太る的ななんか運動だけどやっぱ
食べる量とか何を食べるかそういう部分で
本当にマジでねバカみたいに太った友達と
かもいるしなんかほんと健康の気をつけ方
1つで
相当変わるのかなって思います
[音楽]
え
俺最近大丈夫だよね
大丈夫大丈夫だと思うあ
再検査だけ精密検査がやばいのか
脂質系だけはちょっとギリギリセーフだっ
たみたいな感じですけど大丈夫じゃない
良かった良かったいやこんなところで気を
抜いていきませんもう本当にいつ誰がどう
いう病気になるかわかんないからもう今の
うちに本当に健康を噛みしめていきたいな
と思ってます
怖いよ本当に俺最近家族とかもさもう登山
観察じいちゃんばあちゃんも結構
俺も含めて年いってるからさなんかこう人
は平等に歳をとる生き物だから本当みんな
気をつけましょうね健康とか今回はまあ
現状維持というか結果良かったんです
けれども今年1年も
体に気をつけて
生活していきたいと思います
特に食生活ですねほんと深夜のバカ食いと
かマジで気をつけようと思います今年1年
も健康に気をつけて
頑張ります
ごちそうさまでした
[音楽]